bonjour bienvenue dans ces caches les
missions économiques que vous pourrez
regarder pendant vos longues soirées
très très longue depuis le couvre-feu à
21h
bonjour aujourd'hui on va se poser la
question de qui va payer la facture
bonjour estelle bonjour olivier bonjour
à tous bienvenue dans ce nouvel épisode
de ses caches pays en récession
endettement la crise économique
engendrée par le cos vite 19 devrait
laisser une facture salée qui va payer
la note les épargnants vont-ils être
forcé de mettre la main au porte monnaie
se sont allés questions qui vont nous
occuper dans ce nouveau numéro et pour
en parler nous serons en deuxième partie
d'émission en liaison avec virginie
pradal présidente de l'institut de
recherche fiscales et économiques
vauban mais d'abord olivier pour
commencer vous voyez ces chiffres 7
milliards de dollars de pib c'est ce que
le coronavirus aura fait perdre à l'est
que l économie mondiale d'ici la fin
selon as les prévisions de l' ocde
l'endettement des pays a lui aussi un
s'alourdit en france au deuxième
trimestre de cette année la dette
publique a bondi de 2 100 milliards
d'euros elle s'élève aujourd'hui à
environ 114 % du pib une hausse qui
s'explique notamment par le financement
des nombreuses mesures mises en place
par le gouvernement pour lutter contre
les effets de la crise liée aux côtés de
19,6 le gouvernement a martelé qu'il n'y
aurait pas de hausse d'impôt sur le
revenu les épargnants eux pourraient
être amenés à régler la note
voyez pourquoi avec le tiroir cage
d'antoine basse
[Musique]
mais où aller chercher les 200 milliards
d'euros de dettes publiques du deuxième
trimestre 2020 pas les impôts sur le
revenu jean castex et emmanuel macron
l'ont dit ils n'augmenteront pas pavin
mois de la présidentielle c'est
politiquement ruineux et en plus pas
forcément efficace puisque ça ralentit
l'activité ou alors taxer certaines
grosses entreprises qui s'en sont sortis
au mieux ces derniers mois du côté de la
fraude fiscale peut être non plus reste
l'épargné est oui selon le fc eux les
français auraient accumulé 55 milliards
d'euros sur les deux mois du confinement
enfin en grande partie les plus riches
la moitié serait le fruit du 10 % des
français les plus aisés 20% des ménages
les plus modestes n'aurait même pas
réussi à mettre plus de côté taxer
l'épargné
ça s'est déjà vu l'italie en 1992 avait
prélevé 0,6 pour cent de l'epargne de
ses habitants ou chypre qui en échange
d'un plan d'aidé européen avait taxé
certains dépôts bancaires à hauteur de
47,5 pour cent pas d'affolement
toutefois pour l'instant en tout cas le
gouvernement compte toujours sur un
rebond économique une reprise tant
attendue pour redonner la santé à une
économie bien mal en point
[Musique]
olivier les épargnants la cible idéale
pour payer la facture selon vous alors
si vous voulez il ya il ya déjà
plusieurs années puisque c'était du
temps de mario draghi
répondant à une question d'un
journaliste après une conférence au pour
une réunion de la bce mario draghi avait
dit ça il ya un moment où on ne pourra
plus taxé le contribuable parce que en
effet c'est contre-productif et puis qui
trop c'est trop
donc trop d'impôt tué l'impôt et donc il
avait dit faudra passer aux épargnants
et s'était passé comme une lettre à la
poste un personne n'avait broncher
évidemment personne n'avait dit tiens il
est en train de dire quelque chose
d'intéressant pour une fois et donc
c'était s'était passé comme ça
facilement mais ça prouve qu'ils y
réfléchissaient déjà et je vous parle de
ça il ya il ya bientôt dix ans et donc
ne pensais pas qu'ils ne le feront pas
il est évident que de toute façon c'est
la facture actuelle est tellement
importante que ils n'auront pas le choix
alors ils augmenteront les impôts alors
ils les appelleront autrement ce que
vous voulez mais ils augmenteront les
impôts et probablement il taxeront
l'epargne et pas forcément d'ailleurs
sous forme d'un impôt nouveau mais
simplement en prenant sur les assurances
vie ou en prenant sur les comptes
directement
donc c'est pas un risque forcément ils
le feront vous avez quand quand vous
avez une dette tels que la dette
actuelle
et ça c'est pas uniquement la france
vous avez aujourd'hui tous les pays qui
fonctionne de la même façon donc quand
vous avez une bête qui est tellement
importante alors vous pouvez toujours
faire comme bruno le maire et vous
raconter des histoires en vous disant
que c'est la croissance future qui va
payer la beta c'est une blague
qu'elles soient remboursées avec seul
euro seul un rebond économique aussi les
repas de rebond économique
regardez les mesures qui ont été prises
à vous pensez que ça va amener un rebond
économique croyez moi tout les tous les
restaurants nous faire faillite
c'est clair c'est marquer vous avez déjà
des gens qui avait entre 50 et 60% est
maintenant ils vont en avoir 80 ans et
ont même des mesures pour tenter de
contrer le nombre de maladies pour nous
et quelle mesure quelle mesure fasse je
veux dire est ce que est ce que vous
pensez que le virus il se réveille à 21h
et il y vient toquer à la porte des
restaurants qu'à 21h mais pas avant on
va revenir sur le sujet de cette
émission est les épargnants olivier pour
cela on passe tout de suite à la
deuxième partie de cette émission
et cette semaine nous sommes en liaison
avec virginie pradal bonjour vous êtes
présidente de l'institut de recherche
fiscales et économiques vauban bienvenue
dans ces caches merci d'avoir accepté
notre invitation
bonjour alors pour commencer
virginie pradal voudrais vous faire
réagir à ces différentes déclarations
nous ne reproduirons pas l'erreur de
procéder à des hausses de la fiscalité
qui affaiblirait notre croissance et
enverrait des signaux négatifs aux
ménages et aux entreprises précision
signée jean castex lors de la
présentation à du plan de relance de
l'économie française un peu plus tôt à
c'est emmanuel macron le 14 juillet qui
l'a assuré déclarant aucune trajectoire
fiscal avait été votée on ne résout pas
une crise comme celle ci en augmentant
les impôts même constat chez bruno le
maire le ministre de l'économie a pour
qui est le remboursement de la tête se
fera de la dette se fera par la
croissance virginie pradal toutes ses
promesses sur la non augmentation des
impôts est ce qu'elles sont nobles selon
vous va écouter les promesses n'engagent
que ceux qui les écoutent un donc ceux
qui les écoutent et qui ont envie d'y
croire encore ils peuvent le phare et
pour toutes les personnes qui en ont
assez et d'écouter ces mêmes promesses
qu'on entend
qu'on entend depuis plusieurs années
j'ai vraiment envie de dire depuis
plusieurs décennies bailly les savent
qu'ils savent à quoi s'en tenir
moi je partage totalement le constat
d'olivier il va forcément y avoir une
augmentation massive de prélèvements
obligatoires mais bien entendu
n'attendons pas une déclaration
tonitruante d'un nouvel impôt pour les
classes moyennes pour les les plus
pauvres ce sera fait de façon dissimulée
comme c'est déjà le cas depuis plusieurs
années un parce qu'il faut bien
comprendre que le gros des prélèvements
obligatoires est complètement dissimulé
on a certes une fiscalité spectacle
quand il s'agit de taxer les plus riches
les contributions exceptionnelles à gogo
parce que rappelons qu'en période
normale on a déjà chaque année des
contributions exceptionnelles encore
période exceptionnelle vous même pas
imaginer ce que ça va être pour
certaines entreprises ou pour certains
contribuables très aisés
en tout état de cause ça se fera de
façon dissimulée comme l'a dit olivier
par le biais de l'assurance vie parce
qu'on sait que c'est là où il ya
énormément d'argent mais aussi par le
biais d'une hausse du prix d'électricité
une nouvelle taxe sur les jouer comme
cela a été suggéré enfin il ya mille et
une façons d'augmenter les prélèvements
sur les français ans et plus et cachez
plus c'est efficace et c'est forcément
la voie que va adopter bercy et je tiens
quand même à préciser que hier le fmi a
appelé les différents pays pas seulement
la france est le seul visé parce que
salon la france mais à augmenter les
impôts des plus aisés en augmentant
notamment les taux d'imposition maximum
1 marginaux à ce que vous savez qu'on a
des taux d'imposition progressif et en
taxant le capital le capital mobilier
comme immobilier et je tiens aussi à
préciser qu on a déjà un rapport qui
nous propose d'augmenter très fortement
les cotisations des entrepreneurs qui
dirige le rsa est donc on a déjà pas mal
de propositions sur la table pour
augmenter les prélèvements obligatoires
la france a elle est déjà championne en
matière de pression fiscale selon les
sondages
les recettes fiscales justement
représenté 46 5 1% du pib de l'hexagone
à croire encore accroître encore cette
pression c'est un pari quand même
presque mais c'est risqué mais comment
dire c'est pas une bonne idée
d'augmenter les prélèvements
obligatoires parce qu'on voit que ça
génère énormément de fraude d'évasion
rappelons quand même que la france est
un pays exportateur de riches
aujourd'hui on est en train de nous dire
que quand il ya eu quand même eu
plusieurs propositions visant à taxer
davantage les riches à un moment faut se
poser des questions tout il ya quand
même tout un tas de rapports
internationaux qui met en évidence que
la france exporte ses riches et plus
particulièrement ces millionnaires
depuis plusieurs années alors c'est bien
entendu des rapports dont on n'entend
jamais parler hein parce qu'on n'aime
pas du tout aux intérêts en parler on
préfère donner des chiffres un peu
ridicule enfin on essaie de nous laisser
penser qu'il ya quelques dizaines de
riches qui partent chaque année mais en
fait c'est beaucoup plus cinq ans quand
on regarde les études sérieuses qui sont
faites je pense notamment à des études
faites par une banque asiatique qui
dispose d'un panel assez représentatif
de millionnaires et qui se base sur les
visas pendant la chaussure sur des
éléments un peu plus sérieux que ce
qu'on a dans le débat actuel en france
et y mettent en évidence que par exemple
dans le top 10 mondial des pays
exportateurs de riches bas la france est
7e
non et pourtant on n'a pas la même
population que d'autres pays
exportateurs comme la chine comme la
russie donc voilà c'est un phénomène qui
est qui est incroyablement développés a
fortiori dans l'union européenne parce
que rappelons quand même comment de la
liberté de circulation on a supprimé
tous les dispositifs anti exil fiscal
quand on a supprimé emmanuel macron à
supprimer tous les dispositifs anti exil
fiscal donc aujourd'hui les portes sont
grandes ouvertes est taxé à nouveau les
riches
à mon avis c'est ce qui va arriver d'une
façon ou d'une autre parce qu'à un
moment la situation va être tels que si
c'est pas emmanuel macron ce sera le
prochain gouvernement ça se fera d'une
façon ou d'une autre mais je vois pas
comment on pourrait y échapper la
situation et la pression de l'opinion
publique va être tels que ça va
forcément arriver
et c'est regrettable mais je vois là
sauf un miracle économique et non comme
disait olivier moi je ne crois pas aux
miracles
donc voilà on peut se parler on peut y
réfléchir pendant les longues soirées de
confinement olivier une réaction à cette
phrase de françois lenglet journaliste
et auteur du livre à quoi qu'il en
compte au bout du bout et va bien
falloir se débarrasser de cette dette et
on ne peut pas s'en débarrasser sans
détruire du capital c'est à dire de les
pannes d'été et pannes sont les deux
faces de la même pièce si vous êtes
endettés c'est bien que quelqu'un vous
apprêtez vous à prêter son épargne c'est
inévitable cette destruction de capital
selon vos souliers oui et le problème
pour rebondir un peu aussi sur ce que
disait virginie je pense que
malheureusement les augmentations
d'impôts ils vont elles vont porter
toujours sur les mêmes
c'est à dire sur la classe moyenne les
riches ils sortent du pays donc ils
seront pas imposées plus et ça fera
partir les quelques qui continuer à
rester et à s'accrocher au bateau france
désespérément mais les autres sont déjà
parties et donc en fait ça va retomber
toujours sur les mêmes c'est à dire ceux
qui gagnent un petit peu d'argent sans
être riche
la deuxième chose que je voulais dire
par rapport à ça c'est que
malheureusement si nous n'exportons que
les riches mais on exporte aussi tous
les talents un des chercheurs les les
gens qui pourraient nous apporter de la
croissance et qui eux partent
je vous rappelle la dernière
la dernier le dernier prix nobel de
chimie qui est une qui est une femme qui
est une française
sauf que elle est partie on suit souche
et plus on met donc y partent ils
partent et ils partent pourquoi parce
qu'ils en ont marre de se prendre des
taxes et et ils en ont marre d'un état
qui bientôt je vous dis rentrer chez
vous puisque vous n'avez plus le droit
de d'invités six personnes chez vous
donc on est dans quelque chose qui est
qui est une dérive et qui est une dérive
qui forcément arrivera à une conclusion
est la conclusion c'est en effet on vous
prendra votre et pape d'une manière ou
d'une autre
alors vous avez la technique de l'impôt
vous avez comme le disait monsieur
draghi la technique de de prendre de
servir directement dans les assurances
vie ou sur les comptes de dépôt vous
avez l'immobilier aussi très
probablement qui va être taxés parce que
c'est là qu'il ya de l'argent il n'y a
pas il n'y a pas besoin d'avoir fait
polytechnique 1 vous avez deux endroits
où vous avez de l'argent en france vous
avez les parts des ménages avec
l'assurance vie et vous êtes plus
particulièrement constitué par
l'assurance vie et vous avez
l'immobilier donc ils vont taper dans
les deux il n'y a pas deux il n'y a pas
de miracle alors dû à comme le dit
virgine très probablement de façon
insidieuse et et pas avec des
déclarations tonitruantes
mais ils le feront et saufs
il ya une deuxième méthode mais
malheureusement c'est pas c'est pas un
bouton sur lequel on peut appuyer qui
est de souhaiter tous les jours que ça
parte en ce qu'on appelle
l'hyperinflation qui est un mauvais
terme d'ailleurs pour désigner ce que
c'est c'est à dire la chute de la
confiance dans la monnaie et à ce moment
là votre épargne ne vaut plus rien vous
pouvez vous allumé un petit feu avec ça
va bientôt être l'hiver donc pendant le
confinement vous pourrez vous faire un
feu avec des billets qui ne vaudront
plus rien du tout c'est les 2 c les deux
techniques si vous voulez vous pouvez
pas faire vous pouvez pas en inventer
d'autres si vous avez le défaut de
paiement mais le défaut de paiement
c'est compliqué parce que ça veut dire
que vous prenez une décision de ne pas
rembourser évidemment tous les gens qui
d
sienne des obligations et c'est pas que
madame bettencourt ou monsieur bernard
naud ceux qui détiennent des obligations
ils en ont dans leur assurance visant
non dans tous les produits bancaires
le livret a cessé d obligations et donc
si vous fait défaut
malheureusement ça se paye c'est à dire
que vous rendez des gens qui vous ont
prêté de l'argent pas content alors
avant d'aller plus loin on va marquer
une courte à foison revient dans un
instant bienvenue à danser cachez vous
rejoignez on parle les épargnants
ont-ils un devoir régler la facture et
pour cela nous sommes en liaison avec
virginie pradel présidente de l'institut
de recherche fiscales et économiques
vauban virginie pradel on l'a vu un an
le tir marquage notamment à taxer les
pannes ça s'est déjà vu en italie
notamment où l'ensemble des dépôts
bancaires des italiens avaient été taxés
au 2e de 0 6% en 92 chypre aussi il a
fait un temps en france si l'on part de
l'hypothèse que les épargnants vont
devoir régler la facture
quelle forme pourrait prendre
cet impôt en quelque sorte est ce qu'on
peut imaginer aussi des taxes sur les
dépôts bancaires comme ça a été fait en
italie
hamon on peut tout imaginer mais de
toute manière à bercy ils ont beaucoup
d'imagination il suffit de regarder tout
ce qui a été fait au cours des années
précédentes car moi je penserai
peut-être dans un premier temps à
quelque chose de peut être moins
agressif parce que là c'est quand même
la solution de dernier ressort mais faut
bien comprendre que tout a été prévu en
amont pour saisir le cas échéant
l'argent des épargnants vous avez
aujourd'hui une disposition dans les
législations européennes à une
disposition européenne qui prévoit que
dans certaines circonstances vous pouvez
pas récupérer les avoirs que vous
détenez sur un compte bancaire delà de
100 mille euros
vous avez une autre loi il me semble que
ces sapins qu'il a fait adopter qui vous
pointiez empêche les épargnants de
récupérer le principal de leur assurance
vie ici bas tous les épargnants se
mettent à vouloir récupérer leurs
assurances vie en même temps par vous
avez plein de choses vous avez aussi la
possibilité d'augmenter l'électricité ça
je pense qu'on va pas l'échapper parce
que l'électricité aujourd'hui et un prix
trop faible 1 et qui va bien falloir un
jour payer l'électricité au juste prix
j'ai envie de dire il ya tout un tas de
choses
moi je pense qu'on va augmenter les
cotisations parce que les cotisations
c'est quelque chose qui passe bien on
dit toujours que c'est pour financer le
modèle social donc j'ai quand même
l'impression que dans l'opinion publique
augmenter les cotisations passe mieux
que augmenter les impôts mais voilà
c'est moi je
j'attends de voir mais en tout état de
cause ou sinon on va peut-être assister
à une réduction des niches fiscales
ça ce serait aussi envisageable mais bon
là ce serait au détriment de nombreux
secteurs économiques tels que
l'immobilier où l'emploi à domicile donc
aussi délicat jeu je sais pas je suis
pas vraiment mais bon je fais confiance
aux grands esprits de bercy on sait que
on sait que on sait qu'ils y
réfléchissent
du matin au soir donc attendons
patiemment olivier à une réaction
quelle forme cela est ce que vous
pensiez
il ya deux ans que on se retrouverait on
se retrouverait avec un couvre feu à
partir de 21h non personne ne le pensait
et personne ne pouvait l'imaginer
donc aujourd'hui essayer d'imaginer ce
qu'ils vont nous sortir comme façon de
piquer l'épargné des ménages
personne n'en est capable vous verrez
qu'ils vont trouver une solution ça je
n'ai aucun doute là dessus et que
et que ça ne sera pas la croissance qui
remboursera l'espèce de gabegie qui a eu
depuis et pas depuis seulement le coc
vide depuis des années parce qu'on l'a
on est on est tous en train de parler du
que vides comme si c'était le mais ça
n'est qu'un accélérateur leleu la
récession elle était là avant les les
banques centrales avaient déjà commencé
à déverser depuis très longtemps de la
monnaie sur sûr de faire tourner la
planche à billets donc c'est pas quelque
chose de nouveau
la dette le fonctionnement sur la dette
c'est pas quelque chose de nouveau le
fait qu'on est qu'on soit en déficit
budgétaire c'est pas quelque chose de
nouveau
là c'est simplement le fait que ça
grossit ça accélère et que aujourd'hui
sont dans une telle situation qu'ils
font n'importe quoi ils font n'importe
quoi sur la gestion sanitaire et puis il
faut aussi n'importe quoi sur la gestion
financière sur la gestion financière
vous êtes à un moment où le tout ce
qu'ils ont fait avant ne suffit plus à à
camoufler le trou et et il faut trouver
autre chose
et croyez moi ils trouveront autre chose
parce que ils n'auront pas le choix
c'est pas une la reprise on parle tout
le temps de la reprise bruno le maire
nous parle de la reprise la reprise elle
va arriver comment avec les petits bras
bruno le maire qui va s'agiter dans tous
les sens et qui va nous créer de la
croissance
non c'est pas comme ça que ça se passe
le l'état n'a jamais apporté croissance
nulle part ça n'existe pas ce qui
apporte de la croissance et des
entrepreneurs qui créent des choses et
qui vendent des choses qui sont utiles
donc c'est ça la croissance mais c'est
pas c'est pas bruno le maire qui
s'agitent en disant on va avoir de la
croissance qui va rembourser la dette et
virginie prennent juste pour terminer on
concrètement techs et l'épargnant ça
revient
clairement à créer un nouvel impôt ah
oui non mais vous il ya mille et une
façons d'augmenter les impôts et impôts
fin voilà faut juste raisonnée de la
façon suivante qu'est ce qui vous reste
à la fin que ce qu'est ce qu'ils
voudraient j'ai juste une petite chose à
ajouter
moi ce qui me sidère c'est que le
gouvernement ne rebondit pas du tout sur
le rapport de la cour des comptes est un
ouvrage qui a quand même suscité un
certain tollé de charles prat au regard
de la fraude fiscale de la fraude
sociale par contre la fraude fiscale
hors là par contre on a plein de mesures
liberticides 1 pour lutter contre la
fraude sociale
la fraude fiscale pardon je m'en mets
les pinceaux mais en matière de fraude
sociale
rien n'est fait et ça représente quand
même des dizaines de milliards d'euros
est ce que je trouve regrettable c'est
que le gouvernement n'est apparemment
pas décidé à prendre des mesures de bon
sens pour lutter contre ce fléau et que
certes lutter contre la fraude sociale
ne permettra pas de financer la dette
relative aux colis d'un mais ça
permettrait quand même de limiter
l'argent qui pourrait être prélevées
indûment d'une façon ou d'une autre
encore un rapport le ça ne prendra
certainement pas la forme d'un impôt
mais cet argent qui va être prélevés in
fine et sur les épargnants on va tous
payer collectivement cette facture se
sera pas les plus riches parce que les
plus riches qu'on ne peut pas les taxes
et en les manuels bakr on l'a bien
compris les riches sont mes nouveaux
joueurs de la mersey soir exemple we
believe au plus ça pourrait rapporter
aller 1 1 ou 2 milliards d'euros
quand ça va pas financer la dette du coc
vide c'est donc il ya beaucoup de gens
qui par idéologie mais par pure
idéologie en faisant fi du contexte dans
lequel se trouve la france à savoir une
union européenne
ultra ouverte et très dogmatique aussi
dans un sens un pas est ce que vous ne
la circulation au nom de la liberté de
circulation comme je vous l'aï dit tout
à l'heure on a quand même évolué tous
les dispositifs qui permettait aux états
de protéger leurs bases
leurs bases fiscales dans leurs bases
d'imposition aujourd'hui quand vous êtes
une personne aisée
vous avez juste à prendre un petit
billet de tgv pour aller à bruxelles
vivre plus de six mois dans l'année là
bas et voilà vous n'êtes plus imposables
à gaza et ses pensées quand même ce qui
s'est passé au cours des dernières
années il suffit d'aller faire un tour à
bruxelles à genève ou encore à londres
pour se rendre compte ou encore au
portugal à lisbonne fin j'en passe
il ya plein de paradis fiscaux pour les
plus aisés au sein de l'union européenne
fin d'ailleurs c'est pas des paradis
fiscaux c'est nous qui sommes un enfer
fiscal pour les riches et les autres
sont des pays normaux voilà donc je
pense que ce sera pas la voie qui sera
adoptée par emmanuel macron est encore
et toujours les riches ce sera la classe
moyenne
ce sera vous moi les gens qui
travaillent les gens qui essaient
laborieusement de faire quelques
économies pour se financer un bien
immobilier ou financer une assurance vie
etc qui vont payer les errements
budgétaires et pas seulement de notre
gouvernement actuel et des précédents
merci beaucoup virginie pradal d'avoir
été parmi nous dans cette émission je
rappelle que vous êtes président de
l'institut de recherche de recherche
fiscales et économiques vauban olivier
on continue avec les questions cash
merci virginie
olivier comme chaque semaine vous
répondez aux questions des internautes
voici celle sélectionnée cette semaine
celle de florian angoulême les
assurances vie au luxembourg même en
fonds euros garde-t-elle une sécurité du
fait de l'inexistence de la loi sapin
dans ce pays
non alors on vient d'en parler on vient
de dire que les français dans leur est
pas leur épargne était constituée
principalement d'assurance vie et que
donc il y avait beaucoup d'argent dans
l'assurance vie et que l'état allait
probablement d'une manière ou d'une
autre se servir dedans alors la loi
sapin de us c'est juste une loi qui
bloque votre votre assurance quand par
exemple il ya trop de demandes de rachat
mais en revanche si demain le
gouvernement se met à taxer
l'assurance-vie par un impôt par une
taxe exceptionnelle et c'est que vous
soyez au luxembourg où que vous soyez
partout dans le monde ça ne changera
rien donc c'est vraiment le principe de
l'assurance vie et le principe de
l'assurance vie en plus il ya il ya
quand même quelque chose qu'il faut bien
comprendre l'assurance-vie ca à 85 %
sont des obligations les obligations on
vient de franchir le record aujourd'hui
de 2,2
de la partie obligataire qui est tantôt
nul ou négatif
donc comment voulez vous que ça
fonctionne vous ne pouvez pas avoir un
produit qui est essentiellement
obligataires dans un monde où les
obligations ne rapporte rien ou même
coûte de l'argent et vous dire que c'est
une bonne idée
c'est une mauvaise idée l'assurance vie
alors on sait pas très bien quand il va
y avoir des problèmes mais aujourd'hui
l'assurance vie c'est une mauvaise idée
ça a été un excellent produit qui était
défiscalisées qui était intéressant
parce que sans risque et qui rapportait
quelque chose aujourd'hui c'est un
mauvais produit et c'est en plus de ça
il faut bien le comprendre quelque chose
qui est éminemment risque et donc
n'allez pas là dessus
sachant que le l'état va s'occuper de
vous merci beaucoup olivier c'est la fin
de cette émission merci de votre
fidélité sachez que vous pouvez adresser
toutes vos questions à olivier sur les
réseaux sociaux en commentaire et des
vidéos si vous souhaitez revoir cette
émission rendez vous sur notre site
internet à l'adresse rt france point tv
olivier le mot de la fin pour tondre un
mouton il faut l'empêcher de bouger
maintenant c'est fait à partir de 21h
vous ne bougerait plus vous serez chez
vous